Apple just released the brand new M2 Pro
and M2 Max MacBook Pros and they look
great but there are many things that
Apple did not tell you both on the
positive and on the negative that's
going to change your buying decision now
I'm not going to waste your time with
all of the specs but I do want to let
you know that we are doing a worldwide
giveaway of a new Macbook Pro and a Mac
Mini and all I've got to do is subscribe
enable notifications and comment below
which you could do on each new Mac video
we make for more chances to win we're
going to choose the winners live on
February 1st so don't miss out on that
video now the first thing they didn't
tell you is that these MacBooks Were
Meant to come out months ago we had many
leaks that pointed to that but they
didn't come and after this event
multiple people online mentioned that
this video was scrapped from the October
event and Ian Zelda went in and download
metadata from the AR and from the
wallpapers that clearly show what they
were created in October ready for for a
November release now the second thing is
that there are way more changes under
the hood than just the performance that
they are quoting we have this whole chip
layout and one thing that was pointed
out is that the tlb buffer was really
increased if you don't know with the
original M1 Pro and Max laptops we found
out in our testing that the GPU scaling
was not good at all especially with the
M1 Max now the way that these Apple
silicon chips are designed you have a
base ship that M1 and M2 and that gets
duplicated to make the larger chips and
it should scale properly but when we
looked at the performance it was not
good at all for example if we're even
scaling from the 14 core M1 Pro we
should have 80 000 for geekbench 5 but
in fact we had 68 000 and that is
because there was an issue with not
enough memory buffer and that was the
bottleneck but now we have reports where
that was greatly increased and improved
so not only you're going to have the
quoted performance that they gave on
their website but in certain
applications the scaling will be much
better now we ordered 10 new M1 Pro and
M1 Max machines so we're going to be
doing a ton of testing with real world
programs and we will see what the
performance will be like for example in
blender we should have way faster
results with the 32 core compared to 24
but we didn't so if you guys want to see
how they actually perform make sure to
click that subscribe button and enable
notifications now for the third one we
have to talk about the course apple is
showing off a 12 core system two more
than before and that sounds great but
what they're not focusing on as much is
that the two extra cores are actually
efficiency cores meaning the performance
cores are staying exactly the same now
that might not help as much with
performance but that is gonna really
help in terms of battery life which I'm
going to come back to next we have to
talk about the architectural design and
the performance now we had many leaks
with this chip being three nanometer and
tsmc launching these we've covered all
of that and with AMD going to four
nanometer and it might be an in-between
point a lot of people thought these
ships could be four nanometer just like
the a16 but no they are still based off
of 5 nanometer which is a bummer because
that means that it will run hotter and
use more power just like we got with the
M2 Chip compared to the M1 what we have
effectively is an overclocked processor
running more power to get more
performance but that also affects the
Heat and thermals and throttling which
we're also going to talk about but on
the plus side this also means that it's
cheaper and easier for apple to make
these with better yields and that also
means better availability but before I
die dive deep into the performance and
other things they're not talking about
you need our sponsors must have app for
your new Mac clean my Mac X which is
notarized by Apple and has been on the
market for 14 years I bought it three
years ago because it's simple but
powerful and takes only seconds to
install and use their assistant provides
personalized tips and smart scan will
automatically clean up protect and speed
up your Mac in seconds which removed
almost 10 gigabyte of my junk files you
can also dive deeper where I found a
bunch of files I did need along with
malware protection and removal and an
installer that doesn't leave leftover
files and categories as apps so I could
easily see what I haven't been using as
well as an Easy Auto updater
optimization and maintenance gives you
control to easily fix your system and
space lens is super cool visually
showing my large files where I found a
55 gigabyte phone backup I deleted plus
a sensitive file Shredder this app has
been great to use with its assistance
recommendations and the menu that shows
a ton of System Info with tools like
memory free up with one click clean my
Mac is giving a 30 discount for two
weeks after this video is released just
make sure to use our down the link in
the description below now the next one
is about the performance and clock speed
now on Apple's website they talk about
the increase in performance uh being up
to 20 more powerful in terms of the CPU
and then 30 in terms of GPU and they
mentioned that it's in the same power
envelope but the thing is with the M1
Pro and Max a lot of times they didn't
actually hit their Max rated CPU wattage
now Apple didn't mention the clock speed
the M1 Max and pro they would run at up
to 3.2 gigahertz but based on the leaks
that we have seen this thing goes up to
3.68 gigahertz likely 3.7 and that is a
big jump from 3.2 now the way they show
off their benchmarks is they show up the
maximum performance not what you
actually get and we also know from our
testing that these Macs got really hot
already hitting over 100 degrees Celsius
and we did have thermal throttling a lot
more so on the 14-inch model but even
the 16 inch model with throttle because
of too much heat because of too much
wattage so with this one running higher
clock speeds means it will pull more
it'll pull more for longer and for
longer renders we might actually have
more throttling so that pretty good
score in geekbench which is not limited
by heat might go down and the 3.68
gigahertz might also drop down quite a
bit for longer renders of course we
bought multiple configurations because
we will be testing them out and telling
you guys which one is worth buying and
next let's switch to some positives now
with the previous MacBooks the 16 inch
actually was heavier with the M1 Max
than with the M1 Pro because it had a
better cooler but the 14 inch model was
the same which also led to more
throttling but thankfully this time
around if you go over to switch to the
14 inch you go into the fine specs you
will see that the 14 inch M2 Max now
weighs 3.65 so it's heavier than the M2
Pro instead of being the same so
hopefully they have stronger fans in
this to help with cooling now the next
one is battery life and this is a
positive now with this launch Apple gave
it a one hour better rating for both the
14 inch and the 16 inch model but in my
opinion it's going to be a lot better
than that and that is because I have
tested the M2 Chip already now I
mentioned that we now have 12 cores and
instead of having two efficiency cores
we have four just like with the M2 and
the M1 chips but those cores are way
more powerful meaning that because of
extra power and doubling the cores for a
lot of tasks you can just use those
efficiency cores and not even touch the
performance ones now with the M2 MacBook
Pro and air I did testing with a low
power mode that basically switches off
the performance mode and even though
things do take longer especially tough
productivity it is still more than fast
enough and smokes Windows laptops in
real world use while getting insane
battery life now with that machine Apple
quoted empty MacBook Air slightly better
in battery life and in real world we got
about an hour better but when we enabled
the low power mode the CPU and GPU
wattage drops like crazy becomes
extremely efficient and instead of going
from about 9 to 10 hours I got 15 hours
of real world use which is insane so
with this machine the new 14 and 16 inch
laptops if you're going to use low power
mode it will actually be able to do so
instead of basically making very little
difference with the current 14 and 16
inch your battery life is going to get a
lot better and that is a great thing now
the next one is minor but interesting
with these MacBooks we have the mini LED
displays that look amazing they hit up
to 1600 nits beautiful beautiful HDR
great for color grading HDR video and
photos but this time around if we look
at the fine print I've not seen this
before it literally says in temperatures
less than 25 degrees Celsius which is
around 77 fahrenheit meaning that now
they're telling us once the Mac gets
warmer you're outside or in a warm room
you're not gonna get that full
performance now the next one is pricing
now here in the states the prices stayed
the same even though I think it's
costing Apple a little bit less to make
these instead of doing like a three
nanometer now if we actually go and
account for inflation though that 3 500
for a spec like I have here actually
turns into about 3 800 meaning that
technically it's a little bit less
expensive for us but with that said in
other parts of the world it
unfortunately got a lot more expensive
for example in Denmark it went up by
about 220 Euros or 300 bucks in England
it went up by 300 pounds which is about
370 bucks and even in Canada by a
hundred dollars now one guy in Denmark
said that he bought a 14 inch one
terabyte discounted for 2300 USD now
these new ones are 3 300 that's a huge
price Gap and apple had some great sales
recently and he's asking should I return
it and get the new one I would say for
that big of a price difference I would
not do that and surprisingly in
Singapore they actually got Cheaper by a
hundred dollars so pricing is all over
the place and it does suck that it got
more expensive in some regions next we
have connectivity now this was mentioned
on this slide but I really have to
emphasize this because these are the
first Macs that have Bluetooth 5.3 along
with Wi-Fi 6E other Windows laptops and
Android phones have had this for a long
time and it's great that Apple added
this even though the M2 MacBook Air did
not get it now this is great if you have
a new router and you're in a congested
area because you have that special band
better for Speed and if you guys saw my
video on Apple possibly making another
Wi-Fi air power router we have a lot of
leaks about this and that would be very
cool to see so I'm glad apple is finally
stepping it up now with that the next
one is the 96 gigabytes of RAM that is a
lot of ram to have I think it's more
than enough or too much for most people
but if you want to get that what they
advertise on screen you have to have the
38 core M2 Max the most expensive
version of that now I always do videos
where I compare different amounts of ram
so with all the MacBooks that I bought I
will be comparing 64 gig and 96 along
with 16 versus 32 and even 8 versus 16.
so if you guys want to see videos on how
much of a difference that makes for
different real world tasks the next one
we need to talk about connectivity now
we were so excited to have HDMI again on
a MacBook but people are disappointed
because it only supported 4K 60 with old
school HDMI but now not only they show
up that they have updated HDMI what they
didn't tell you is that this is
something that nobody else really has
the empty Pro supports up to three
external displays which is great but the
M2 Max now supports up to four external
displays which is a lot you could use
all three of the Thunderbolt ports along
with that HDMI and not only can you now
do 4K 120 or you could do 6K 60 you can
actually do 4K 240 frame per second
which is absolutely insane now the crazy
thing is now the crazy thing is if we go
to hdmi.org the main website the latest
HDMI 2.1 a says they can only go up to
4K 120 frames per second because that is
the maximum bandwidth so apple is using
something that is even better than the
best announced version now that is
because they are using display stream
compression to make this happen it adds
very very little latency and it allows
you to have higher resolutions have HDR
10 bit and super high frame rate so I'm
glad the apple is putting in the latest
tech into this now the one thing that
you have to know is that if you want to
make this work you have to have a good
cable because there are so many fake
hdmis HDMI 2.1 could actually be older
it's crazy so you have to make sure you
buy the right one now I did some
research and found a set of cables that
are index offensive but they have the
best ratings that will support anything
that the laptop can output so I'm going
to go ahead and Link that down below now
along with that we have memory bandwidth
and RAM the M2 Chip got faster than M1
but Apple didn't mention that the Mt Pro
and Max they did not get any faster
they're just advertising how fast it is
so they're sticking with the same exact
Ram speeds as before and along with that
the next one is the neural engine the
neural engine they're showing off the 16
core one and they're not saying that
it's the same exact one as with the M2
Chip so if you're doing tasks that are
based on the neural engine more AI stuff
even on photography a lot of stuff is
using that now it might not be any
faster or much faster than just having
an M2 MacBook Air and the last one that
I have for you guys is the fact that
finally the charge cable with magsafe
that's braided color matches the space
gray on the laptops now the one I got
for myself is space gray so that is nice
just like with the M2 MacBook Air but
that's just a simple one let me know
which one surprised you the most once
again make sure you comment down below
and check out each one of our new videos
uh from the time of the launch on
Tuesday up to February 1st and comments
so that you can have a chance to win
either a MacBook Pro or a Mac Mini we've
done these giveaways many times before
we ship them out we pay for everything
so it's great click that Circle above to
subscribe to see more videos check out
one of those right there and if you want
to buy one of these MacBooks check out
YouTube shopping feature this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next one
foreign